crash tests show electric vehicles hold
up well in a collision the extra weight
from their batteries help better protect
the people inside but safety Advocates
worry the extra hundreds and sometimes
thousands of pounds present a potential
growing danger to other drivers this
Crash Test shows what happens when a
sedan is hit by an SUV weighing nearly a
thousand pounds more the smaller car
suffers noticeably more damage GMC's
electric Hummer can go 0 to 60 in
roughly three seconds while weighing
more than nine thousand pounds over
three thousand pounds more than GMC's
full-size pickup and its battery alone
comes in at about 2 900 pounds roughly
the same as a Toyota Corolla the
electric Ford F-150 weighs up to 2500
pounds more than its gas-powered sibling
and rivian's pickup weighs in around 7
100 pounds while the average vehicle on
the roads today weighs closer to 4 300.